je vous croyais à la retraite mon vieux
que vous aviez une nouvelle vie
regarde tu n'as qu'à les emmerdes
qu'est-ce que tu veux j'aimerais voir
mon fils
je savais qu'il te laisserait partir
j'ai pas arrêté de prier
je pensais me retirer des dents la merde
tueur à gage tu as des ennemis et
oublié génial j'aimerais voir ça tu sais
que tu peux pas t'enfuir
ramène le petit
a des conséquences
le réservoir je cherche mon fils
tu vas rentrer comme si de rien n'était
[Musique]
maintenant comment
dis-moi où est mon fils
toutes les choses que j'ai faites
et c'est là que je m'apprête à faire
que Dieu est pitié de mon âme
et maintenant tu vas devoir payer